In this lesson, we're going to take a look at a few more things with Lumen, and then
we're going to go and jump in and look at exposure control when it comes to setting
up your scene.
So let's get started.
So we built our scene out and we brought in a post-process volume controlling some of
the quality in here as we need.
Now again, a review of some of that, we can actually, if your scene supports it, and remember
some of these are GPU expensive and if you increase them, you need to keep in mind what
your GPU can handle.
So I can increase my lighting quality as well as my scene detail if I wish.
Now my system is a bit stronger than some others and I can go in here and even increase
my final gather if I need to.
Now as we do this, you can remove some of the noise, but you have to keep in mind some
of your materials, which was mentioned in other classes before, where you can actually
adjust the material roughness.
And when you adjust the material roughness, you're able to remove some of the noise.
Now some of the noise may still persist so that you can still use some C-Vars to clean
that up.
But keep in mind that Lumen is still evolving as it grows and gets stronger, faster and
better.
You will need to be very deterministic about your shots, your materials and your angles.
And you'll notice here in this particular shot, there's a little bit, just a little
bit of noise over here on these rough areas compared to over here where it's a little
bit higher, where there's a lot more bouncing and refracted areas.
We also want to go in here and go to our project settings.
In my project settings, I want to go in here and look at my static light.
The reason why I want to do this and make sure that static light options are off is
I want to make sure that they're not pulling anything unnecessary in my scene.
So I'm going to turn off my allow static lighting.
I'm also going to make sure that I turn off my ambient occlusion static fraction.
And you'll see mine's already off.
Now this will require a restart.
So let me go ahead and restart this and we'll go back into our scene.
Now you'll notice if we float over that tick box that we turned off, Unreal will give
you a breakdown saying you should really turn this off.
That way it allows the bent normals and the luminal global illumination to actually calculate
those correctly.
And it really just is not needed.
And you're saving some overhead there.
So you want to make sure you turn that off.
Now that was covered in the first class, but I just wanted to remind everyone about that.
So let me go ahead and close these two windows.
So we have our scene in here and we're looking pretty good, but we want to maybe try to get
it so that our exposure is really at a level that makes sense.
So from ground up, you can say, let me close this window too.
Don't need it at this time.
So what we want to do is go into our content drawer.
I'm going to click on engine and I'm going to type in calibrator.
I'm going to pull in my SM color calibrator.
I'll pull this into my scene and I'll drag this one outside for a moment.
This is going to give us the best possible results for our exposure and allow us to be
able to pull in what we need.
Now, before we do that, I do want to mention scalability.
This is very important when working with Unreal to determine what your computer can handle.
Now in older settings, it was found up at the top and older versions of Unreal, but
you can now find underneath your settings here, scalability, engine settings.
Everything I have is set to epic, but if I wanted to, I can also set things to cinematic.
My computer can handle that.
But you can also have auto here.
Now when you set auto, Unreal will determine based on your computer, the best settings
that are needed and can accommodate what you have under the hood.
Now let's go back to the slides.
I'm going to take a look at a few points I want to make clear and some things you have
to adjust before we go forward.
So in our project settings, there's a few things we need to make sure that we turn off.
One of them is bloom.
We want to make sure that bloom is turned off.
And AO.
Now you can turn them on.
I usually turn them on to turn them off or make them zero.
And that way, if I need to go back to them and turn them back on, I can easily do so.
Also turn off auto exposure that's in the project settings.
Any vignetting that you have in your post-process volume.
And turn off your extended default luminance range.
That will require a restart.
So just keep that in mind.
Some people may want to keep this on so that you still have a little bit of a auto calculation
for your distance and your luminance.
I prefer to actually turn that off.
But it's really up to you as you decide to dive into these deeper.
Let's go ahead and take a look at some of these things in Unreal and mess with these
settings.
Okay, so let's go ahead and go into the project settings and change some of those things.
One, let's go and type in bloom.
So you can see I have bloom turned off.
And you want to have this one turned off initially.
Next we want to go in here and type in AO.
So we want to make sure that our, or you can just type in ambient inclusion.
Maybe a little bit easier so you don't get a thousand things.
Turn off your default ambient occlusion as well as the baked one.
You don't need that.
And you want to keep things pretty pure, especially if you are baking.
You want to make it so you're starting off from scratch.
You can go in here and change a few things later on as you go.
Next we want to also go in here and change our extended.
Make sure we spell that correctly.
We need default luminance range in the auto exposure settings.
We want to make sure you turn that off.
We also want to make sure auto exposure isn't on.
I almost forgot about that one.
So auto exposure, you want to turn that off so you're in control.
And I'll show you how you can actually reactivate that.
But within the post process volume, which is actually pretty nice.
Also, if you did inherit something from the marketplace, you want to go into your post
process volume.
And in here, you want to go in here and you want to look for vignetting because someone
may have turned it on and you may not even know.
And you can see in this case, we have it on.
We can turn that off.
We don't want to have that on.
That makes it so you have a pure scene.
You know exactly what it is you're getting exposure wise.
And it's pretty beneficial.
So now we want to go ahead and take a look at our exposure and see the amount and judge
exactly what we have with those settings, everything else in place.
Now that we're in unreal, I'm going to go and move over to the outside where our calibrator
is at where we left it.
And I'm going to look at the third gray square from the right side here.
And we're going to use a thing called a pixel inspector.
This pixel inspector will allow us to go in here and to be able to judge exactly what
it is on our color exposure.
Pretty much looking at our exposure, I should say, and looking at the color in that pixel,
the luminance of it, I should say.
And it's going to tell us exactly where we stand with things.
Now you'll see it here right where it says debug.
You'll go down to pixel inspector.
Want to click on pixel inspector.
Let me drag it over.
We're going to turn on the start pixel inspector and we see there is a luminance here that
we want to focus on.
And it says luminance before tone map.
I'm going to float over and it's going to give me what that is for that particular pixel.
And we can see that it's 7.5.
But that's not exactly what we need.
If we go back to the notes here, you'll see that we're looking for a 0.18 or 18% gray.
This is going to be coming back as a 50% in our gray sRGB.
This really does depend on the scene, but we can actually adjust things and correct
things to what we need.
Let's go back into Unreal and do that.
With the pixel inspector active, we can now use it so that we can analyze that scene again.
So let's go and do that.
Go to debug again.
I'm going to go to our pixel inspector.
And again, you click on the magnifying glass.
We can now inspect where our luminance is at.
Now we can see that our luminance is pretty high.
So to be able to fix that, we're going to go in here and adjust our strength of our light.
And we're going to lower this to like a 4.5.
You can even keep it at 5 if you want to.
But we can now check with the pixel inspector.
And we're pretty close with our luminance before tone map.
So we can actually get this just to 4 and see what we get.
And then do that again.
Pretty close, but not quite there.
And we'll get that intensity adjusted.
So we'll do a 3.5.
There we go.
3.5 it is.
Now with that set up, I can now go in here and control my exposure.
So I've adjusted the light here and I can go in here and now in my scene, go to my post
process volume and turn on a few things.
Now if we look at exposure up close, you'll notice we do have a default bloom intensity
and threshold.
So I can turn these off if I want to.
It's up to you how you do this.
Realize when you do turn on bloom and crank that up, it could actually make things a bit
blown out.
We'll close mobile because we're not in mobile.
We'll close bloom for now.
And we're going to mainly focus here.
Now there's several different ways that you can choose your exposure.
There's an auto exposure, which I prefer, because then I can lock it down within a range.
Let me show you what I'm talking about, particularly the minimum brightness and maximum brightness.
So if I do adjust that and turn on auto exposure, I can keep my minimum and my maximum within
a particular range and it will help adjust according to my settings and what I have in
place.
Now, I, a lot of the times, will set this simply to one because then everything works
as a simple EV slider and I can choose whether I want it dark or I want it bright right there
within my scene.
And I'm in full control of everything and I know exactly where my exposure lies and
how I've set it.
You can also choose to do auto exposure basic and a few things will be grayed out as you
go and change between these, as well as you can also do manual, which is pretty straightforward.
We're just mainly messing with this again, like an EV breakdown, but you'll notice some
of these are grayed out and no longer such as the minimum brightness and maximum brightness
are no longer adjustable when you're in manual.
But again, I like auto exposure.
Call me an old school game head for me.
That helps me be able to adjust this.
And if I did want to create a minimum and maximum to get that auto to be able to control
within a range, I have that choice.
It's really up to you how you want to do it.
And we can set these to default and you can see the auto exposure kind of adjusting itself
as I go from one room to the next.
I look in different areas.
You will notice too, off to the right here, we have a thing called a exposure compensation
curve.
You can load these and build the curves yourself.
There are some default ones that come in here.
If I double click on this, this curve now is able to be adjusted and will affect my scene.
Now, some of it might be very minimal when you move these around, but it's up to you
how you adjust it and how you move things and how you edit things accordingly.
If I grab the whole line here and move it up and down.
You'll see things slightly change.
You got a little brighter and I'll move this down.
You'll see it get darker.
So it does have an influence.
It just may seem a little bit weak in here.
It's up to you how you adjust that curve.
I'm going to turn the curve off.
We don't need it.
And they can definitely see the dramatic change.
There is a exposure meter mask.
You could also load if you wanted to.
But all these things are at your fingertips to be able to control your exposure.
There are a few materials to keep in mind when working with Unreal 2.
So this particular one has a very distinct material in here for our glass.
There's a frosted glass effect in here.
You will see the noise because lumen and some materials may not play necessarily nicely.
It may give you a bit higher noise.
So keep that in mind.
And this particular material, if you slide over, is a spiral blur texture, scene texture.
So you can experiment with some of these materials.
Some of them I'm not really sure some that will work and not work.
You have to.
It's always a case by case.
And also lumen is constantly evolving, getting better and stronger.
But you can definitely see the noise coming through on this blurred effect.
In this particular case, you may want to just use an alpha mask that is a bit more 50 50 gray.
And per using it within the material, because we definitely are getting a bit of noise there.
Here is a list of CVARS that you can use to be able to run and experiment with your scene.
And they are available to you.
But let me show you some quick tips and tricks when working with these CVARS in Unreal.
A lot of people aren't aware in Unreal you have the ability to actually call upon the CVARS at any time,
because they do disappear if you just work in your output log down below.
But you can use a tool that we have set up for you that allows us to be able to go in here.
And let me go ahead and find this guy.
This is just an added added bonus that I'm adding to this course.
We got to turn him on.
So if I go to plugins here.
We turn on console.
You'll see there's a thing called a console variable editor.
Let me turn mine on and give it a restart.
And you can actually see kind of how cool it is.
Now that I've restarted, I'm going to go in here under windows and pull up a thing called console variables.
This console variables allows me to add any console variable that I have in my commands.
Say I've worked on a few and I've added a few.
I can place them in the console variables.
Worked on a few and I've added a few.
I can place them here and I can even save those presets that I already have in place and call upon them whenever I need them.
It's really nice.
So you don't have to worry about punching stuff into the command line here and seeing it disappear or no longer working as an on when you close in real.
You can actually load it through your console variables.
Very handy.
And also if you get stuck and you're like, I'm not sure which Lumen ones I have.
I have maybe I don't have Sean's a magical PDF.
You can go into your console variable search table here that is built under help here.
If you go down just about four lines here, you'll see console variables.
Click on that and you're going to get quickly navigated to an area where you can look up that console variable that you need.
Pretty nice.
And I can simply just type in Lumen.
So everything that has to do with Lumen is now going to come up into my search.
And it gives you a description for each item to which is really helpful.
Well, that's it for this class.
Here's some more information that you can click on to be able to actually dive a bit more into auto exposure and other exposure properties when working with unreal.
In the next section, we're going to take a look at the old school way to bake your lights in using the bake lighting system in unreal.
You.